[Music]
people out there are probably wondering
why okay that seems like a legitimate
question why conan
why are you doing your shooting on a
miniature set well it's very simple okay
a couple of weeks ago we introduced a
new character called puppy conan
yeah and puppy conan uh had to live on a
tiny little puppy conan set along with
puppy andy and uh it was a fun segment
and at the end of it i got carried away
and i made a little bit of a vow take a
look
[Applause]
we also have added a puppy cameraman
tonight to catch all the action
[Applause]
i love this set i swear to god what i
want to do is an entire show on this set
some night
wouldn't that be great
we got to do that
now my rule is if i say something on
camera and the audience cheers i have to
do it that has been
for example if for example if andy were
to get a sex change
stay all right
it's gonna go
storming off this set looks so sweet no
no i was like well i've had it i know i
was oh you were going to swim and go go
to sweden there's a there's a cheap
place over in north hollywood oh okay
i've heard about that well anyway uh
because they were the inspiration for
tonight's show i thought we should bring
them out here they are puppy conan and
puppy andy let's get him on here
[Applause]
[Music]
hey dustin how does it look now
looks good huh yeah very good this is
the hair you were going for all right
he's a sweetie boy you're a sweetie boy
yeah all right i was
that's a very strange haircut on puppy
yeah
he's shaking only slightly less than i
am yeah come on sweetie